- [Narrator] So you're at
a New Year's Eve party,
thinking of kissing someone at midnight?
Let's try some other traditions,
like the ones involving
snacks, because we get hungry.
(upbeat music)
Excuse me, coming through.
Watch your back.
Take Spain, where they
eat a grape for every bell
that strikes at midnight.
Whoa, slow down Sam, it's just 12.
Even more delicious?
Switzerland, they eat whipped cream.
It's customary to let
some spill on the floor.
If you're looking for
something more healthy,
look to Chile.
They eat a spoonful of
lentils at midnight.
Uh yeah, lentils.
Okay, too healthy.
How about the Netherlands?
The dutch eat special sugary doughnuts.
It's better shared with friends.
Okay, I know what you're
thinking, where's the booze?
Enter Russia, there it's
customary to write your wishes
down and burn the paper.
The ash is then dropped
into some bubbles and drunk.
Mmm ashy.
Still hungry?
In Japan they eat buckwheat
noodles which represent
longevity and wealth.
Speaking of wealth, if you're
the lucky one to find the coin
in this traditional Greek bread,
you're promised good
luck for the next year.
Yay, looks like Kimberley's
in for a good year.
But something that's
found around the world,
good cheer, good friends,
and maybe a few great big stories.
[All] One, happy new year!